between the time you were last here you
did that 40th anniversary of Saturday
Night Live and you said that was like
the best night of your life and I
haven't even asked you about oh my gosh
I mean because you've seen a lot of [__]
go down Howard this was abandoned all
and I'll be all this was the best party
I've ever been at and then at the after
party that's the thing I keep reading it
sounds like the after party in a way was
better than the actual broadcast it was
so good that you couldn't even imagine
too bad they didn't tape that I know I
think someone did and like Prince got it
all taken off yeah he did yeah he
doesn't like yeah Prince wasn't on the
actuals he came to the the after party
yeah he like floated into the after
party this is so this is what happened
yeah I go to the party so I walk in it's
at the plaza right so it's beautiful
right it's Gordy walking up marble steps
and you go this is what you think every
silent Live party is yeah of course it's
not you know right it's at like a
Chili's you know and uh so we we go up
and I go oh my God and it's great I see
uh I forget who I mean then you run into
like a thousand people yeah and uh I get
a drink yeah so I ordered a gin and
tonic and right as they put it in my
hand they go uh Jimmy Paul Paul is
calling for you on stage Paul McCartney
is calling free calling for you yeah I
get up I go uh Paul McCartney everybody
goes let's do uh sorry stand in there or
something like that he crushes he
crushes so then I'm looking in the crowd
for who I can bring up next because now
now this is the game I'm DJing you're
keeping the party with real human being
right so I go I see Taylor Swift I go do
you want to get up and she goes uh okay
so Taylor Swift get that she's awesome I
said let's play uh shake this is my new
song Shake It Off it never went nuts it
was the night of that like keeping each
other but then I gotta be honest Miley
Cyrus is amazing she's got a great voice
and is cool and she looked at me and she
goes you want me to get up like made a
face like I'll do it I'll keep the party
going good she got up it was a jam out
what a [__] night what time of night
is this like it's now it's four or five
I would be asleep I'd have missed
everything that's what everyone everyone
said oh I missed it Chuck how do you get
Prince up on stage that night all right
so we get everybody up on stage and then
it starts getting crazy where I don't
know what's happening Chris Rockets up
so we're singing something me and Chris
and Maya and Chappelle gets up and he
goes hey my my friend uh my friend is
here he's uh he's a great harmonic
player I go sure you can come up why not
right he goes he's here with Prince oh
and Chris goes you should get Prince to
get up here he goes I don't know how
you're going to do that so I go uh I go
Prince uh are you if you're there come
on up and play something so all of a
sudden the room gets quiet like what
can't just call princess all of a sudden
the crowd parts and this is like Jay-Z's
there Beyonce's in the it crashes parts
and you see like a purple cloud and I'm
not kidding I was looking it's like an
optical illusion his feet weren't
touching the ground I know it was like
David Blaine trick it was like he he was
placing heels and he's it's almost like
his knees were up too he was like he was
just kind of floating it's like yeah it
looked like a like someone had a dummy
or something they were pulling it
through like he magically appeared it
magically appeared and it was honestly
okay Doug Henning trick and and he he
comes floating in and he goes he has
these long gloves on he takes his gloves
off and he hands me his gloves I I like
I'm Jerome yeah hold hold the glove
you're that guy yes yeah you're right I
hold princess gloves they hand him a
guitar and he does an unbelievable
version of Let's Go Crazy wow he does
the hit which is weird which is what you
want right the guys give it up the good
guys give it up wow he but he's the guy
who never gives it up
he the place melted
foreign